[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
les parlementaires européens condamne
l'agression militaire russe
le 5 mars 2022 près de 200
parlementaires européens ont cosigné une
déclaration condamnant avec force la
guerre menée par la russie contre
l'ukraine
les parlementaires étaient rassemblées à
paris dans le cadre de la présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne à l'occasion de la réunion de
la conférence des organes spécialisés
dans les affaires de l'union
avec cette déclaration cosignée par les
présidents de délégation parlementaire
de tous les états membres et de six pays
candidats à l'entrée dans l'union ou
voisins les parlementaires européens ont
affirmé leur soutien unanime à l'ukraine
appelant à un cessez le feu immédiat il
condamne avec force la guerre menée par
la russie contre l'ukraine avec la
complicité du bélarus et juge nulle et
non avenue la reconnaissance d entité
séparatiste autoproclamé de l'ukraine
par la russie
se félicitant des sanctions adoptées par
l'union européenne envers l'agresseur
les parlementaires appellent l'union à
s'organiser pour accueillir
solidairement les millions de réfugiés
ukrainien et à renforcer son soutien à
l'ukraine
à cette fin ils font valoir la nécessité
d'associer les parlements nationaux à la
gestion de cette crise
à plus long terme les parlementaires
demandent au chef d'état ou de
gouvernement d'approfondir la politique
de défense et de sécurité commune et de
parler d'une même voix sur la scène
internationale
il estime que les incidences du conflit
sur les cours des produits céréaliers et
de l'énergie confirme l'urgente
nécessité de renforcer l'autonomie
stratégique européenne particulièrement
en matière alimentaire et énergétique
pour en savoir plus consultez la
déclaration de la conférence des organes
spécialisés dans les affaires de l'union
[Musique]